what did what happened in the 80s if you
remember is we evolved from your hair
looked like the aftermath of a Los
Angeles forest fire why who is in your
circle that let you walk outside with
that goddamn cookie crumble hairline
that's it looked like the Oreo topping
on a [__] McFlurry you listen
your family won't do it but let it go r
b is dead I understand but your hair
follicles done went with it your [__] is
cooked my guy that's not well done
congratulations Mesquite no sauce
you got a char-broiled hairline I never
in my life seen grill marks on a goddamn
forehead before what are you doing
listen my parents own a black beauty
supply store so I already know what
happened you walked into the store you
saw the Korean couple you said excuse me
let me get the begin Oriental black with
those two oriental people gave you the
be gone cause your [__] is dusted enough